تشجيبتيه برنامج الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي
اصبح حديثا العالم لقدرته الفائقه على
كتابه النصوص وحل شفره البرمجه وحتى تاليف
النكات والسيناريوهات الافلام القصيره
البرنامج الذي لا يزال تحت التجربه خلق
حاله من الجدل الواسع في مدارس وجامعه
العالم ما بين تقييده او الاستفاده منه هو
عدو جديد للمحاضرين والمعلمين الطلاب
يعتمدون على روبوت الدردشه الذكي لكتابه
مقالات واعداد الابحاث في ثواني معدودات
لكن اصوات اخرى
بنتائج عكسيه على العموم بسبب هذا الجدل
خرجت خدمه زيرو وهي مخصصه للمعلمين وتتمكن
من تحديدا نصوص التي تم تنفيذها بالذكاء
الاصطناعي رغم ذلك بدات طلاب في مشاركته
على مواقع التواصل
[موسيقى]
طيب بعد اعلان مايكروسوفت دمج تقني الذكاء
الاصطناعي في منتجاتها هل قلق المعلمين
مبرر يعني طبعا التقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي
تتطور بشكل مخيف صراحه ومرعب واصبحنا الان
نجد الكثير من
الاشخاص لربما يستخدموها بشكل غير اخلاقي
احيانا او غير صحيح من اجل طبعا انشاء بعض
او تسليم بعض الابحاث والتقارير التي فعلا
نوع من القلق وهذا طبعا بلا شك ياخذنا الى
نوع من التفكير كيف فعليا يجب علينا اداره
مثل هذه التقنيات بشكل صحيح يعني في في
اطار التعليم طيب
تقنيه تشالشي بيتي تحديدا لماذا اثارت كل
هذا القلق يعني حتى له الماسك اعتبرها
نعتق نيه ممتازه لكنها خطيره صحيح يعني
بلا شك طبعا هي التقنيه ما بعرف اذا
جربتيها سهام تساليها اي سؤال ويقوم
بالاجابه ولكن الخطر انه ما لازم
نثق في المعلومات 100% لانه هذه التقنيات
التي تستخدم طبعا الريزانيج او التفكير
واي مبنيه على ما يسمى الديب وتعلم العميق
احيانا في هناك نوع من الاخطاء يعني علميه
يعني وبالتالي على سبيل المثال لو سالتهم
من فاز في كاس العالم لا تستطيع ان تجيب
لانها طبعا دربت على بيانات قديمه قبل
على الاختبارات هل انتم مع حظرها تماما عن
قطع تعليمي مع استخدامها لجهه الاستفاده
منها لكن بحدود من دون نتائج سلبيه انا
اراك دكتور الجامعه وادرس يعني انا ارى
اظن انه خطا انهم نحذف او نلغي الوصول الى
مثل هذه التقنيه لا بالعكس يجب علينا ان
نضع اطور جديده تنظم اليه استخدام مثل
ويكيبيديا قبل سنوات كنا نخاف ان الطلاب
تقوم بنسخ المحتويات لكن انا برايي لا
نفتح هذه الجوله الجديده نجرب المعلمين
والمدرسين والمدرب الطلاب كيف الاستخدام
الامثل والامن بمثل هذه التقنيات لانها
سوف تساعد ايضا لها تطبيقات جدا مفيده
ايضا في تغيير طريقه التدريس والتعلم
[موسيقى]